in five years we could well be spending
one trillion dollars a year interest
only on the debt young people are
getting [ __ ] and we also asked voters
who they would pick for the US Senate
seat Democrat incumbent Martin Heinrich
Republican contractor mitt Mick rich or
libertarian Gary Johnson also New
Mexico's former governor we're gonna
have knocked on over a hundred thousand
doors which is very significant so we
got a pretty good ground game and we'll
just we'll just have to see yeah he's a
very personable guy very intelligent guy
and I'm glad he's back in New Mexico
maybe he'll stay the step dude I'm
hoping that we left him for Senate I
wish she was running for governor thank
you sir will you be voting for Gary oh
yeah oh that's great yeah thank you
I don't know what kind of chance she has
but we do have a sensitivity on hello
voter my name is Justin I'm a volunteer
concerned with corruption in Washington
DC
do you consider yourself more
conservative liberal or independent hey
Donald how you doing my name is David
I'm the lawn chair concerned with
corruption in Washington DC and wanted
no duty more conservative liberal or
independent all right surveil okay
excellent you try and hook them a little
bit more and tell them a little bit
about what Gary did with his governor as
a Republican Governor Gary Johnson
vetoed 750 bills lowered taxes and cut
the budget by 10% without firing any
employees can we count on your vote for
just a conservative Gary Johnson oh if
they bite on that it segues into ol Gary
Johnson blurb Gary Johnson was a former
governor of New Mexico and during this
time
of course I either pothead
would you think Gary Johnson the former
Republican governor or Martin Heinrich
who would you think is a better option
in that race Gary Johnson okay excellent
I'm not going to vote for him so don't
worry about it okay bye
now buh-bye your call has ended please
enter your results now a quick question
have you ever smoked pot I do
occasionally yes and yes we should
legalize marijuana and in 1999 tomorrow
we'll come back to it mr. rich have you
ever smoked pot man when I talked about
we need to let her yell oh come on when
the last times that Martin smoked and
when was the last talk about it it'd be
hard to remember the last time you
remember yeah yeah well presidential
race in 2016 was still having to tell
people who I was and the disbelief that
went along with your actually running
for president in United States and
you're a what libertarian and what's
that and who are you and why were you
even born as opposed to running for US
Senate having served as governor here
for eight years and having everybody
know who you are and so it's been a lot
of fun really and I'm getting to run for
the US Senate in a three month race what
a gift
there's a misunderstanding when it comes
to public lands east of the Mississippi
what what is public lands what everybody
thinks public lands are riparian areas
but
but there are Czech checkerboard lands
just right here this is checkerboard as
you look out over the horizon it's red
squares and black Spurs and I do mean
geometric red squares and black squares
the red squares being public black
squares being private so what you'll see
oftentimes is Rancher so-and-so tone so
has twenty thousand private acres and
twenty thousand least acres how does it
always work out 20,000 20,000 well
because it's checkerboard so they passed
legislation that says that you have to
be able to access public lands well [ __ ]
how do you access a black square without
going through a red square you can't
it's not possible why not sell those
lands to the land holders and put them
on the put them on the tax rules or
property tax rolls as opposed to the
lease that currently takes place
[Music]
we have to cut back on militaries
[Music]
so I was more outspoken than any
governor in the country regarding school
choice
[Music]
I got to tell you if you haven't ever
done it
climbing to one of the tops of one of
those Peaks it's a scramble but oh my
gosh
there's some serious pucker in doing
that step if you were to slip which
you're not gonna slip but if you were to
slip you die my mom would say to me that
she she didn't where'd you where'd he
get it Gary where do you get it well
it's you mom no it's not me Gary it's
you where where did you get it what's
the matter with you son don't really
Gary for governor this is my mother
reelect Gary so he doesn't go to Mount
Everest please
because he's going
[Music]
might be 50% of the grid terrific ah
terrific
right now there's a cap on the amount of
wages it's subject to Social Security
you can raise that recently there was a
military budget increased by about a
hundred billion you know Udall and
Heinrich both voted for it I was
wondering what your thoughts were on
that well I would have voted against it
against it believing that the biggest
issue that's facing the country right
now is the deficit didn't attack after
he was governor went on a little
vacation and climbed Mount Everest
[Music]
the hope that remains within me is to
potentially win and if that were to
happen or it would be really close
potentially there could be thousands
thousands of candidates nationwide that
will line up next election cycle that
would not have done that otherwise but
for my results for example I love the
last few months but if I don't end up
being u.s. senator from New Mexico I am
done I I will ski a hundred days this
season at Taos I will ride the
Continental Divide mountain bike race
next year for the third time and I'll
get back to the dream that I hoped my
life would be at some point and I do
live that dream not by mistake
nobody should pay any violence
we also asked voters who they've picked
for the US Senate seat Heinrich came in
with 40% rich in second with 28 and
Johnson close behind with 22 however 11
percent said they're still undecided our
political expert says this race could be
closer than we think